>> Bret: PETER DOOCY IN
DES MOINES, THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL NOT TURN
OVER DOCUMENTS.
HOUSE DEMOCRATS WANT SUPPORT AND
PLACEMENT.
THE PRESIDENT'S ASSERTION OF
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE COMES AS HIS
ELDEST SON MAKES A RETURN VISIT
TO A KEY SENATE COMMITTEE.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE HAS SPECIFICS
TONIGHT FROM CAPITOL HILL.
>> ON THIS BOAT WE HAVE 24 YEA
AND 15 NO.
>> THE FULL HOUSE AFTER THE
ADMINISTRATION ASSERTED
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE OVER CENSUS
RECORDS.
>> THIS BEGS THE QUESTION.
WHAT IS BEING HIDDEN?
>> WHEN WE RUSH TO HOLD PEOPLE
IN CONTEMPT, IT HAS A CHILLING
ATTEMPT ON ANYBODY WANTING TO GO
THE EXTRA MILE.
>> THE ADMINISTRATION ARGUES THE
CENSUS QUESTION WAS ARGUED TO
USE COMPLIANCE WITH THE VOTING
RIGHTS ACT.
DEMOCRATS ARE DEMANDING TO
REVIEW INTERNAL DELIBERATIONS
ALLEGING THE CENSUS QUESTION MAY
ENCOURAGE MINORITIES
PARTICIPATION.
ONE DEPUTY CITED HER IMMIGRANT
MOTHER IS NOW U.S. CITIZEN.
>> WHEN THEY ASK HER ABOUT THAT,
IT WILL MAKE HER HESITATE EVEN
THOSE SHE'S BEEN IN THIS COUNTRY
FOR SEVERAL DECADES.
>> DEMOCRATS KNOW THE
SUPREME COURT WILL RULE BY THE
END OF THE MONTH ON THE
CITIZENSHIP QUESTION BUT THEY
HOPE TO USE THIS COMMITTEE'S
OVERSIGHT POWER TO CREATE A
CONTROVERSY AROUND THIS ISSUE
AND TRY TO IMPACT THE COURT'S
DECISION.
>> DURING AN OVAL OFFICE MEETING
THE PRESIDENT CALLED OUT
DEMOCRATS OVER THEIR DEMANDS FOR
CENSUS AND RUSSIAN RECORDS.
>> WE GAVE THEM EVERYTHING.
NOW THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO TRY TO
WIN THE ELECTION AND I THINK THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC WON'T STAND FOR
THAT.
>> BEHIND CLOSED DOORS,
DONALD TRUMP JR. FIELDED
QUESTIONS FROM SENATE
INVESTIGATORS COMPARING
CONFLICTS FROM HIS EARLIER
TESTIMONY AND THAT OF MICHAEL
COHEN.
THE PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL
ATTORNEY WHO PLED GUILTY TO
LYING AND FINANCIAL CRIMES.
AT ISSUE, APPARENT DISCREPANCIES
OVER THE MOSCOW REAL ESTATE THAT
NEVER MATERIALIZED AND AT THE
TRUMP TOWER MEETING WHERE
RUSSIAN LAWYERS PROMISED DIRT ON
HILLARY CLINTON.
>> I DON'T LIKE I CHANGE
ANYTHING OF WHAT I SAID BECAUSE
THERE WAS NOTHING TO CHANGE.
I'M GLAD THIS IS FINALLY OVER
AND WE ARE ABLE TO PUT FINAL
CLARITY ON THAT.
>> TODAY THEY'VE ISSUED
STATEMENTS ON THE HOUSE CONTEMPT
VOTE CALLING IT "SHAMELESS AND
UNDERMINING CONGRESS'
CREDIBILITY WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE."
SEPARATELY THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CONFIRMED THAT HOPE
HICKS WILL SUBMIT TO A